The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi, I'm Jocelyn, and
today we're going to go
over to the Exam 2 from Fall
2009, and Problem 4,
Parts (a) and (b).
As always, we're going to start
by reading the question.
Boron exists in the gas state
as the dimer of boron 2.
Explain how the fact that B(2)
is paramagnetic, two unpaired
electrons, implies that, in
this molecule, the pi 2p
orbitals must lie at a lower
energy than do the sigma 2p.
OK, so what is this question
actually asking you to do?
Well, it's asking you why the
energy of the pi 2p is less
than the energy of the sigma
2p, given that boron 2 is
paramagnetic.
So the first thing we need to
know is what paramagnetic
means, and he actually gives
that to you in the problem, so
it means that you have two
unpaired electrons.
So this is unpaired electrons.
We are asked here then to give
a reason why the fact that
there are unpaired electrons
implies a certain ordering of
the sigma and pi 2p orbitals.
So the first thing we want to
do, probably, is recognize
that these are molecular
orbitals, not atomic orbitals.
Therefore, we probably want to
start by drawing the molecular
orbital diagram for boron.
Now, how do we draw a molecular
orbital diagram.
Well, the first thing
to do is to start
with the atomic orbitals.
So boron has five electrons,
as we can find out from our
periodic table, and they occupy
the 1s, the 2s, and one
electron in the 2p.
Again, if this seems unfamiliar
to you, you might
want to go back to earlier in
the course, where we went over
electron configuration.
However, when we're looking
at molecular orbitals, we
actually only care about the
valence electrons, because
those are what are involved
in bonding.
The core electrons are much,
much lower in energy, so they
aren't really involved
in the bonding.
So we're actually only going
to look at the electrons in
the second energy level.
So we have three valence
electrons per boron, and they
are in the 2s and 2p, which we
remember, there are three p
orbitals in each energy level.
So now let's draw those in.
We have 2s and 2p.
Remember to always have a scale
here, and we're in an
energy space, and this is not
to scale, because we're just
looking at relative energies, we
don't care about the actual
difference in energy.
And because we have
two borons--
so this is boron one--
I'm going to draw the same
thing over here.
Make sure they're at the same
energy level because they are
the exact same atom,
and therefore,
the same atomic orbitals.
So this is, again, boron,
and we have three
electrons for each.
We don't have to fill them in,
but I'm going to do so, just
to keep track.
And again, we're filling
according to the orbital
filling rules gone over
earlier in the class.
So now that we have our atomic
orbitals, we are going to
combine them to, like,
molecular orbitals.
And we want to remember that s
orbitals combine to make a
sigma and a sigma bonding and
a sigma anti-bonding.
Remember that whenever
you combine atomic
orbitals, you create--
if you're combining two atomic
orbitals, you create one of a
higher energy and one of a lower
energy, because the net
energy stays the same.
Oh sorry, that's crooked.
All right, now we'll move on
to the 2p, and because the
problem told us that we need to
explain why the pi bonding
orbitals are lower in energy
than the sigma bonding
orbitals, we're going to start
with that configuration.
The actual order depends on the
molecule, and so without
any extra information, we
wouldn't really know if the
sigma was above or
below the pi.
So as the question, kind of,
hints at: p orbitals make two
pi bonds and one sigma bond.
This is due to the orientation
of the pi bonds, or the p
orbitals in space.
Then, as always, we need to put
in the anti-bonding just
to make sure we keep track
of all of our orbitals.
OK, so we combined one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
eight atomic orbitals, and we
made one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight
molecular orbitals.
We want to make sure we always
have the same number of
orbitals before and after.
So now we can fill in the
electrons into the molecular
orbitals: that's these
in the middle here.
And we use the same rules as
we do when we're filling
atomic orbitals.
So we start at the lowest
energy, pairing spins, if we
only have one orbital in the
energy level; but as here, we
have degenerate orbitals,
so we can actually
have unpaired spins.
So we have one, two, three,
four, five, six electrons, and
we have three from each boron
atom, and so, we have the same
number of electrons
in our molecule.
Now that we have our molecular
orbital diagram, we can go
back to the actual question.
Some students stopped here
and were like, I made the
molecular orbital diagram.
I'm done.
But we need to remember that the
question is asking us why
the configuration we drew makes
sense because of the
unpaired electrons.
So if we go back to our
molecular orbital diagram, we
see that because the pi 2p have
two degenerate orbitals,
we can have unpaired
electrons.
If we think about the sigma
being below, we would have
paired up those electrons, and
therefore, gotten 0 unpaired
electrons, and it would
not be paramagnetic.
So let's just try that out.
Move over here, and we're
going to draw just the
molecular orbitals; since we
already did the full process
of making them from
the atomic.
So this is the sigma
2s, sigma star 2s.
And now we're just looking at
what if the sigma 2p was lower
in energy than the pi 2p.
And again, we would fill up our
orbitals, and we see that
because this lowest occupied
molecular orbital is
singularly degenerate, we pair
up our electrons, and so if
this were the case, boron would
not be paramagnetic.
However, because it is
paramagnetic, we know that the
pi 2p is lower in energy
than the sigma 2p.
So that's what this question
was asking, and if you said
all those things, great
job, and you answered
the question correctly.
Now we're going to move on to
Part (b), and it's very
related to Part (a), so
we're going to use the
same diagrams here.
So it asks, is the gas molecule
B(2) 2 minus more or
less stable than the gas
molecule to B(2).
Explain.
So here he's asking about the
boron dimer that has a
negative 2 charge-- that is,
it has two extra electrons.
So we're still talking about
boron; and thus the atomic
orbitals that we're combining
are exactly the same.
I'll write that down.
So we have we still have
the 2s and the 2p
from each of the boron.
That's not the same energy
level, and they still make the
same molecular orbitals, but we
have two extra electrons.
So when we go to fill up our
molecular orbitals, we now
have eight instead of six.
So not only is the boron 2 minus
no longer paramagnetic,
because we don't have unpaired
electrons, but we also have a
difference in the bond order.
So if you don't remember what
bonding order is, it is when--
I'll just put it here--
it's how we determine the
strength of the interaction
between the two atoms. And
because he's asking is the
boron 2 minus more or less
stable, we want to figure out
the strength of the interaction,
and that will
tell us which is more stable.
So the bond order is the bonding
electrons minus the
anti-bonding divided by 2.
Sorry that's a little messy, but
I hope you get the idea.
So for boron 2 minus, which
we're talking about over here,
the bonding order: we have
two, four, six bonding
electrons, electrons in
bonding orbitals.
And we have two in anti-bonding
orbitals, divided
by 2 and that gives us
a bonding order of 2.
So that's equivalent to saying
there's a double bond between
the boron 2 minus, the two
borons in that molecule.
So let's move back to our
diagram for the neutral boron
dimer, and we have two, three,
four bonding, and two
anti-bonding, and so
that equals 1.
So in the neutral dimer, we have
a bonding order of 1, and
in the charged 2 minus dimer, we
have a bonding order of 2.
From this, we can see that the
2 minus has more bonding
interaction, and so, it
will be more stable.
So again, you can't just put
that it's more stable, we need
to have an explanation for
why, and this is a way to
explain that.